to train the network he first exposed it
to an example he generated this would
activate the retina and cause a unique
wave of neuron activations to pass
through the network leading to some
output at first this output would
usually be uncertain which is when both
output neurons light up or neither of
them do next he wiggled each knob or
connection weight to try and force the
correct output neuron to activate
starting at the output and then working
backwards through the network and then
he would repeat this process with new
examples and this training process ends
when you hit a point where there is no
tuning needed to get a better output
prediction the network just works Rosen
blat said that abstraction or
generalization must have occurred at
this point and if you just do that long
enough you'll get a network that does
good things once the connection weights
are set you can consider the neural
network as being programmed for the task